♪ (intro music) ♪
Have you ever had an image
or some other box of content in your app
and thought: "Man, I wish
I could just round those corners off
for a bit of polish."
Well, Flutter's
got a widget just for that.
It's called ClipRRect.
An extra "r" stand for "rounded."
You just wrap your widget
with a clipper,
specify a borderRadius--
that's the radius of the circle
we want the corners clipped with--
and you've got yourself
a rounded rectangle.
Widgets like ClipRRect work
by inserting a special Render object
into the Render Tree,
just above their child.
That Render object adds a clip
each time Flutter repaints.
In addition to setting a radius,
ClipRRect has a clipBehavior properties--
so you can customize the Edge.
And if you'd like to try
a different shape,
there're similar widgets called
ClipOval,ClipPath, and more.
For more info on those
and all the other Flutter widgets,
head to flutter.io.
♪ (music) ♪